est-ce que vous seriez capable de tuer
quelqu'un
le con tu en as beaucoup critiqué vos
difficultés à vous exprimer vos fautes
de français etc aujourd'hui c'est fini
ça va beaucoup mieux non j'en fais
toujours autant
[Musique]
Henri Leconte quel est pour vous le
comble de la misère
le comble de la misère c'est
le comble de la misère mais c'est la
santé
à la santé allez à la santé
tu es pour rien tu es la misère tu as
rien tu es plus rien pour moi c'est
le compte de la misère ce qui a de pire
dans la misère le comble de la misère
t'as plus de maison tu as plus rien moi
pour moi le conte de la misère tu
sais pas on prend des grandes enfants tu
as pu tes enfants tu as plus rien c'est
terrible
le compte de la misère pour toi
le comble de la misère c'est quoi
je comprends pas là
la plus belle voiture c'est la mienne
[Applaudissements]
tu vas y arriver le comble de la misère
pour vous Patrick
la solitude la solitude voilà la
solitude quel est votre idéal de bonheur
terrestre de bonheur terrestre votre
idéal de bonheur de bonheur votre idéal
de bonheur terrestre la santé
moi c'était l'amour à la santé au
parloir mais tout le monde s'en branle
Henri pour quelle faute avez-vous le
plus d'indulgence
probablement
[Rires]
quelle qualité préférez-vous chez
l'homme la sincérité et vous oui
et la santé quand même toujours la santé
toujours c'est important
chez la femme pareil
vraiment pareil moi je trouve la
sincérité je crois que
ça c'est en plus
quelle qualité préférez-vous chez la
femme
les deux
est-ce que vous seriez capable de tuer
quelqu'un
oui d'accord ça c'est clair et vous
c'est déjà fait remarquer
[Rires]
Joker
votre vertu préférée
la santé
non je sais pas la rapidité
[Musique]
limite de chef tout ça
et vous
je sais pas si c'est une vertu mais
c'est la générosité
tu vois je suis toujours généreux je
donne tout moi
c'est pour ça que je veux dire qui
auriez-vous aimé être
moi même non sérieusement
j'ai jamais rien
mettre Yannick Noah non pas du tout non
mais je veux dire avant tout tu veux
être toi je n'ai pas envie d'être
quelqu'un d'autre je pense c'est pour ça
qu'on m'aime on me déteste mais au moins
je suis moi-même
et vous qui auriez-vous aimé être si
vous n'étiez pas Patrick Pelou bien sûr
Henri Leconte non je
déconnement Charlie Chaplin ah comment
il s'appelle
mais on a dit que
le principal trade de votre caractère
la santé
c'est marrant tu te fous toujours de ma
gueule avec ça mais c'est vachement
important je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est important il faut tout le monde
pense que ils veulent tous avoir du
pognon des trucs
c'est ça je pense que le principal trait
de votre caractère l'honnêteté c'est
vrai
et vous principal trait de caractère
très probablement
le principal défaut
généreux ça défaut je suis trop généreux
ça peut être une qualité
c'est l'impatience mais ça tombe bien
dans mon métier
quel serait votre plus grand malheur
mon plus grand malheur c'est plus voir
mes enfants
ce que vous détestez par-dessus tout
le mensonge
et la justice au cinéma
surtout chez des gens qui ont fait même
qu'un petit peu confiance
le don de la nature que vous voudriez
avoir Henri
[Rires]
le don de la nature
être
écrivain tiens vraiment un vrai un vrai
écrivain toi un mec qui écrit vraiment
depuis des années qui écrit des trucs
franchement parce que j'ai fait ce livre
en collaboration avec Dominique Bonnot
mais ça c'est vraiment ça m'aurait plu
et vous
le dessin la peinture je dessine
vraiment comme
c'est quelque chose Henri comment
aimeriez-vous mourir
[Rires]
avec non dans mon lit en bonne santé
quand même
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
YouTube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu